it was mad reggie that he lost
here is the reigning mvp with the brawl
moments ago
yogic in a free by curry he's made over
3 000
and a little swather
[Music]
year after that and it took so long to
get back to that stage
you know to finally break through and
you know dallas never had a basketball
championship before
a lot of us is here for trey young we're
talking with dirk nowitzki way outside
three is put in by stephen curry never
forget
curry is male 1
hot drilling at all curry has got 18.
that's so easy and holding it look how
he's holding that goose look at how he's
holding that goose let's not forget he
was born here
[Applause]
here we go video game it's video game
time i can't help but think but what you
set in stride for all these players i
think maybe just maybe i could get to
your weapon you know with strength and
cool coach and all these
and
uh and and if i helped it's inspired
some younger guys from europe now that's
obviously an honor and i'm humble
these harry is on fire from deep that's
eight of 11. it's just an honor and a
tribute to everybody that helped me get
here
it takes a village a lot of people don't
understand the sacrifices that go into
being a professional athlete
knocked down his ninth tray of the right
right you know i mean it's just honoring
him you know i mean just honoring the
people that helped
one leg
i had the opportunity to be a part of
something like that you call it a
blessing i
[Applause]
[Music]
for myself
[Applause]
nba top shop
[Applause]
oh no oh here we go here we go
[Applause]
how much we appreciated being your
colleague for all those years over two
decades and turner and reggie were his
teammate for so many of these years and
d rate he called a lot of your games
with all these three thank you steph
curry thank you steph curry curry a
historic performance and a feed in james
look at this fast stuff
[Applause]
when they get a susic walk in the gym i
can do this
15 threes 45 points
and on a night for the ages he's putting
on a performance
for the ages at the all-star game on tnt
how about the degree of difficulty just
coming down oh i'll stop right here at
37